welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today earlier this week Donald
Trump announced that he was going to
declassify information related to the
FISA warrant obtained on Carter page now
there's been a lot of analysis and
speculation about what this actually
means what it could do to national
security whether or not it's obstruction
of justice all of those are very valid
points we're gonna address those in just
a moment but I want to take a minute to
explain what's actually happening here
this is obstruction of justice it is a
national security problem but more
importantly this is just the next
progression in Donald Trump's attacks on
the special prosecutor that's the main
purpose of this release because it's not
just the FISA information about Carter
page that they're after or that they're
gonna release they're gonna release
testimonies and interviews conducted by
Bruce or they're gonna release text
messages from Andrew McCabe and James
Comey and P or a Bruce or excuse me any
text message that they have related to
the investigation those are gonna be
made public and there's only one reason
to do that and that is to try to paint a
picture of a corrupt intelligence agency
and Justice Department thereby
nullifying the entire special
prosecutors investigation that is the
point of Trump trying to release this
information that is why he constantly
tweets stuff out about lovely Lisa Paige
and Peter struck and their text messages
and how they were conspiring against him
from inside the FBI even though they
really didn't do anything outside of
what was perfectly legal for their
department there is no evidence at all
that there was any wrongdoing on behalf
of any of these intelligence agencies
anyone at the Justice Department
even a Christopher steel himself at the
dossier and yet they're trying to use
selected pieces of information but tell
us that everything about this
investigation is completely fraudulent
and therefore should be shut down
because that's Trump's ultimate goal is
to shut it down or at the very least by
robert muller which is actually gonna
create a lot more headache for him than
muller already has it's a lose-lose
situation for this guy but he doesn't
understand that yet he thinks that he
can fire robert muller paint him as this
corrupt democratic plant and somehow
that's gonna end the investigation big
smiles all around for the trump
administration a happy ending he goes on
to serve 30 more years as president but
really this is gonna backfire
just like everything this man has done
since becoming president everything he
touches turns to garbage every plan he
has falls apart and everything he does
actually ends up giving more fodder to
the special prosecutor they get the
núñez memo right that was supposed to
clear the air and show us how corrupt
these departments are it actually did
the opposite and told us that the FISA
warrant and the investigation itself
were not based on the steel dossier
that's what it said in the Nunez memo it
was not based on the steel dossier yet
to this day we have the president out
there still saying it's all based on the
dirty dossier well let me ask you this
folks let's assume that it was all based
on the dossier that was originally
funded by the Washington free beacon
conservatives then picked up by Hillary
Clinton then actually self-financed
after the Hillary Clinton's law firm
that was representing her stopped paying
so they say Democrats funded it but it's
literally across the board you have
conservatives you have Democrats and you
have self-financing after everybody else
stop paying because they believed it was
worth looking into nonetheless suppose
it was all based on the dossier all
right let's think about that
what from the dossiers been proven false
can anyone you know maybe tweeted at me
what parts of the dossier have been
proven to be false can anyone do that
could anyone point to anything that it
was said in that dossier any point that
was made and say here is the evidence to
show that it's not true the answer is
you can't in fact every claim in there
that's actually been investigated has
been proven to be true we're batting a
thousand over here on this issue folks
and yet Trump is trying to say that oh
they based it on this well first of all
they didn't put second oh four if they
did they probably had a reason to now
let's get to the issues everybody's
talked about here that we mentioned
earlier the national security thing that
is a big issue obviously when you have
these classified pieces of information
they have outside sources that are
sources for the US government in other
countries if you release that
information that puts those sources in
danger either in dangers their lives or
in dangers their will to cooperate with
us in the future
we need those people those are good
sources for the US government and our
intelligence agencies the second claim
is the obstruction of justice
now this 100% could be viewed as
obstruction of justice the big thing
with obstruction of justice from a legal
standpoint is that you have to be able
to show intent what was the intent of
the release of these materials well
Trump himself has made it clear that the
intent is to show that this
investigation is fraudulent that
everything that's happening is
absolutely based on lies based on
nonsense we shouldn't let it continue
and if that's the case then I think the
intent there for obstruction of justice
would be exceptionally easy to prove all
you have to do is look at the guy's own
Twitter feed and luckily we know that
Robert Muller is actually looking at the
president's Twitter feed
people who have gone in to testify in
front of him or talk with him they've
been asked about tweets they've been
asked about obstruction of justice and
this is just the latest evolution of
that and as big as those two issues are
and they are big the obstruction of
justice and the national security threat
here let's not lose sight of the fact
that the reason this is happening is
because this is the progression of the
attacks on Muller Rudy Giuliani made it
very clear a month and a half ago they
were going to step up their attacks this
is what they were gonna do and today
this week it's come to fruition he's
laying more groundwork he wants to fire
Muller he wants to fire sessions he said
just this week I don't have an attorney
general a blatant attack on Jeff
Sessions four recusing himself from the
entire investigation he wants to fire
them all but the problem he has is why
it's gonna backfire you say yeah you can
fire them all day long you're still
required to replace them and there's no
guarantee that you're gonna get a Trump
suck-up in either of those positions or
at least certainly not going to get
somebody who's gonna be willing to
overlook all of the information and
prosecutions and subpoenas that they
already have out there once you're
confronted with that kind of information
and you see what's going on even if you
love the guy probably going to be pretty
hard to ignore that